en los vídeos pasados he dibujado las
curvas de indiferencia de una manera muy
particular déjame dibujar por acá una
curva de indiferencia para acordarnos
entonces en este eje teníamos cantidad
de a y por acá teníamos cantidad de ve y
la curva de indiferencia se veía más o
menos así se veía como una curva que iba
bajando y luego iba aumentando su
pendiente pero siempre era negativa y la
razón por la cual la curva de
indiferencia se veía así era porque si
teníamos muchas unidades de adda digamos
por acá y teníamos muchas unidades de a
entonces estábamos dispuestos a dar pues
varias de esas unidades a cambio de una
unidad de b porque teníamos muy poquitas
dv entonces aquí teníamos una pendiente
muy negativa pero sí teníamos poquitas
unidades de a entonces ahora íbamos a
estar dispuestos a dar menos unidades de
a por cada unidad adicional de be y
porque ahora ya teníamos mucho y poquito
a muy bien bueno la curva se veía así
pero esto se ve únicamente si los bienes
son normales
normales ahorita va a saber a qué me
refiero con que sean bienes normales el
chiste es que hay otro tipo de bienes
que se ven distintos pero bueno en este
caso teníamos aquí una curva de
indiferencia luego podríamos tener una
segunda curva de indiferencia y así
entonces estas opciones las preferíamos
más que éstas y éstas más que éstas y
básicamente se veían como cachitos de
hipérbola verdad en estas curvas se
veían como cachitos de hipérbole pero
bueno déjame plantearte la siguiente
situación qué sucedería si ahora
nuestros bienes nuestros bienes que
queremos comparar no son a hebe sino que
ahora son cantidad de billetes de 100
pesos contra cantidad de billetes de 200
pesos vamos a poner un poco de numeritos
para hacer esto un poco más concreto
aquí le voy a poner 10 aquí le voy a
poner 5 y también 5 y aquí 10
y déjame elegir una opción por acá
digamos esta de acá entonces aquí tienes
cero billetes de doscientos y diez
billetes de 100
estos son mil pesos pero eso es
exactamente lo mismo que cinco billetes
de 200 y cero de 100 ahora mi pregunta
es la curva también se verá así como
hipérbola yo digo que no yo digo que en
este caso la curva siempre se ve así
como una línea recta porque porque no
importa cuántos billetes de siempre
sostengas siempre vas a estar dispuesto
a cambiar dos de esos billetes por un
billete de 200 es decir en este caso la
tasa marginal de sustitución siempre es
de 2 bueno de menos 2 en valor absoluto
es de 2 acá la tasa marginal de
sustitución va cambiando mientras más
unidades tienes de a que estás dispuesto
a dar más de esas unidades por cada
unidad debe pero en este caso como son
billetes de 100 pesos y de 200 pesos
entonces aquí te da pues exactamente lo
mismo no importa cuántos tengas siempre
vas a querer cambiar dos de cien por uno
de 200 a menos claro que seas como
coleccionista pero estamos suponiendo
que no que no hay cosas raras déjame
darte otro ejemplo
signos a un extremo un poco más este
bueno específico vamos a poner acá vamos
a ponerle aquí cantidad de vamos a
ponerle cantidad de lunetas rojas va
entonces aquí le voy a poner cantidad de
lunetas rojas rojas las lunetas son
estos dulces que vienen de colores y así
y luego en verde etcétera bueno y acá
vamos a ponerle cantidad de lunetas
azules entonces esta es cantidad de
lunetas azules entonces a lo mejor está
lo mejor para ti pues es distinto una
luneta roja que una luneta azul pero a
mí me da exactamente lo mismo entonces
sí sí yo tengo digamos 10 lunetas rojas
es lo mismo que si yo tuviera 10 lonetas
azules es decir a mí me da exactamente
lo mismo cambiar una por otra de este
modo en este caso ahora lo que
tendríamos sería una recta
una recta y de indiferencia es decir
sería una curva de indiferencia pero
ahora otra vez sería lineal como aquí
arriba pero en este caso es de uno a uno
sí y aquí son diez aquí son diez y
podríamos tener claro otras otras curvas
de indiferencia en este caso podríamos
tener una más arribita
y déjame ponerlo con con recta para que
se vea bonito entonces si tuviéramos una
más arribita esta sería otra que también
tendría pendiente menos uno aquí serían
como como 15 o como 14 lunetas por 14
lunetas y acá arriba también podríamos
tener una segunda curva de de
indiferencia de billetes pero son
paralelas y siempre son rectas lineales
y son paralelas entre sí bueno este caso
de aquí abajo se le conoce como bienes
que son entre ellos sustitutos perfectos
le voy a escribir sustitutos
sustitutos perfectos perfectos muy bien
entonces la idea es que te da
exactamente lo mismo tener uno que otro
y por lo tanto sus curvas de
indiferencia son líneas rectas con
pendiente menos 1 vámonos para acá que
es un tercer caso que se llama en el
caso de los bienes complementarios o
bueno de complementos perfectos le voy a
escribir en algún lugares son voy a
ponerle
y complementos perfectos por aquí arriba
complementos pigmentos perfectos y justo
como el nombre lo sugiere
son bienes que pues no tiene existe
tener uno si no tienes el otro de nada
te sirve tener uno si tienes si no
tienes el otro es decir no te sirve
tener muchos de uno y poquitos de otro
entonces déjame dibujar un ejemplo y el
ejemplo más típico son zapatos entonces
este lado vamos a poner cantidad de
zapatos izquierdos y acá vamos a poner
cantidad de zapatos derechos entonces le
voy a poner aquí cantidad de zapatos
izquierdos y aquí le voy a poner
cantidad de zapatos derechos entonces
por ejemplo podrías tener uno de cada
uno verdad el zapato izquierdo y un
zapato derecho pero pues si tienes más
zapatos derecho si sólo tienes un zapato
izquierdo
no importa si yo sea cualquiera de las
opciones aquí te da igual porque no te
da más utilidad tener muchos zapatos
izquierdos incluso hasta podría ser
estipuló hasta podría tener utilidad
negativa porque tienes que guardar un
montón de zapatos de sobra pero pensamos
que no que la utilidad es meta entonces
en realidad si tienes un zapato derecho
y un zapato izquierdo es lo mismo que si
tienes un zapato derecho y dos zapatos
izquierdos o tres zapatos izquierdos
entonces en este caso la curva de
indiferencia se vería así sería una
línea que viene así verticalmente y de
modo similar si tienes un zapato
izquierdo tienes un zapato izquierdo no
importa cuántos zapatos derechos tengas
te va a dar exactamente lo mismo claro
si ahora tienes dos zapatos derechos y
ahora tienes dos zapatos derechos pues
si es mejor tener dos zapatos derecho si
los zapatos izquierdos entonces acá
arriba tendríamos una segunda curva de
indiferencia algo de este estilo y así
las curvas de indiferencia van yendo
para arriba así pero pero pues teniendo
dos zapatos izquierdos no importa
cuántos zapatos derechos tengas te da la
misma utilidad bueno entonces estos son
tres casos de cómo se pueden ver las
curvas de indiferencia acá tenemos el
caso de complementos perfectos aquí
tenemos sustitutos perfectos y de este
lado tenemos bienes normales